[Music]
Junior sports Person of the Year
sponsored by teen bridge leisure Alfa
Collier Alfie a member of the Newton
Abbot somersaults has continued to
improve year on year thanks to his
passion dedication and hard work this
year Alfie was chosen to be a member of
the Southwest men's artistic gymnastics
team for which he is represented for the
last six years he also maintained his
place in the southwest tumbling team
2017-18 has been incredible for alfie
winning a stunning eight gold and one
silver at regional and national
competitions in both tumbling and
artistic gymnastics
Rachel fee Rachel has had an amazing
year in the sport of netball culminating
in selection for the England under-19
roses team at just 16 years of age an
amazing achievement in the most popular
girl sport in the country
Rachel was also a member of the highly
successful team bath under-19 squad who
performed exceptionally well in the
England netball Super League this
despite being the youngest member of the
squad and competing against players
sometimes three years above her rachel
has been an ambassador for the sport at
her school excelling across every sport
she turned their hand to in addition to
her netball
roxanna Hallett Roxanna has had an
amazing year with some great results in
both junior and women's events and has
won approximately 1000 pounds in prize
money this all despite being only nine
years old Roxanna has competed in a
range of events and festivals including
an international skate competition
Roxanna has also won a scholarship to
attend camp Woodward in the USA which
she enjoyed immensely
roxanna's achievements include fifth
place at the International NASA festival
2nd place in the UK women's
championships and 1st place at the under
18 girls UK skate jam other achievements
include winning best rate at three
separate competitions thanks to her
silky skills on the board
[Music]